muy buenas tardes te estás suma se
obedece principalmente a la presencia de
productos químicos especialmente
detergentes y jabones los cuales son
llegan a las corrientes por los
vertimientos ya sean industriales o de
aguas
domésticas y que llegan y quedan
depositados al generar
turbulencia debido a las altas
precipitaciones y alaior ya las lluvias
y al aumento del caudal de los ríos que
se está generando esta espuma y es una
espuma tóxica para los habitantes de la
zona tienen que preocuparse
la corporación ha venido adelantando
análisis de laboratorio para identificar
la peligrosidad de estas sustancias que
se han venido evaluando los diferentes
parámetros pero se ha
solicitado a la comunidad que evite que
el tocarla o está cerca de esta espuma
con el fin de que pueda evitar algún
tipo de irritación en la piel o algún
tipo de inhalación que pueda afectar el
sistema respiratorio y ustedes afirman
que ya han comenzado las labores de
remoción de esta espuma tóxica en qué
consiste este proceso y en cuánto tiempo
habrá normalidad en la zona
nosotros hicimos un recorrido en todas
las zonas adelantamos unos operativos de
control y seguimiento ambiental de los
diferentes vertimientos que están
llegando a la corriente hídrica que es
el río arcillas en el municipio de
mosquera y también se empezó a hacer una
limpieza de la fuente hídrica del retiro
de plantas acuáticas especialmente mucho
en esto porque por la temporada invernal
que se está viviendo se ha venido
generando y aumentando digamos su
población y esto está generando un
taponamiento en el río lo que nos
permite una libre y un libre flujo del
agua y genera un estancamiento de las de
testa de esta materia de la espuma y de
iu ya digamos la corporación en compañía
de la gobernación de cundinamarca y del
municipio de mosquera empieza a ser el
retiro de este material vegetal y señor
garcía este fenómeno es recurrente
podría ocurrir de nuevo y que se puede
hacer desde el punto de vista
medioambiental para que nos siga pasando
este fenómeno
generalmente ocurre en época de invierno
por las altas precipitaciones en este
momento colombia o la zona en donde está
ubicado el municipio mosquera ha tenido
un incremento en los niveles de
precipitaciones que no hemos vivido en
los últimos 10 años y estoy alguna otra
forma es lo que ha venido generando este
aumento súbito inesperado de esta espuma
de todas formas la corporación que
adelantará labores digamos ya se
hicieron a la obra civiles porque se van
a dar labores de fondo para solucionar
esta problemática
y la contaminación de los ríos es un
problema extendido tanto en esta región
de cundinamarca como en el resto del
país en toda colombia
en algunas zonas hay ríos muy
contaminados
la corporación de todas formas está
adelantando diferentes acciones entre
ellas la construcción de sistemas de
tratamiento aguas residuales para
mitigar los impactos que telas de los
vertimientos que caigan a los ríos es
estiramos y es importante resaltar que
la corporación acción llama a las
personas a la comunidad para que hagan
un uso racional de los productos
químicos especialmente los detergentes y
jabones porque al no hacer esto estamos
generando un impacto en las corrientes
hídricas y esto nos está perjudicando en
otras zonas que están en otras zonas o
mercados vemos que al hilo de esto que
nos está contando cree que hay un
problema de falta de conciencia tanto en
la ciudadanía como por parte del
empresariado con el uso excesivo de
productos químicos y detergentes
exactamente nosotros creemos y
consideramos que la falta de conciencia
de las personas el uso irracional de
algunos productos químicos están
generando este impacto en las fuentes
hídricas entonces hacemos un llamado a
la comunidad a las empresas para que
comiencen a adelantar las labores de
racionalización de productos y sobre
todo al sector empresarial que ponga en
orden los sistemas de tratamiento para
que los vertimientos que generan cumplan
con la normativa nacional y no genere
ese tipo de impacto